now I've seen a lot of weird stuff in my
day but I've never seen a bull riding a
shotgun well I've rode shotgun is very
similar Nebraska Police pulling over
this guy after folks and towns freaked
out over the side of a wild beast in the
passenger seat turns out the bovine's
name is howdy Duty and his owner takes
him around to parades and fairs in the
states listen I've heard of fast food
but this is ridiculous listen he
obviously spent a lot of time cheating
I'm in town all week please please tip
the bar uh
I don't really have a problem with this
he clearly had his seat belt on of
course his seat belt is a gate and a
rope but he's doing he's abiding by the
rules his hoofs are inside the vehicle
well Jesse I this is overkill now he got
he just got a citation you can't afford
a proper trailer
you know the ones where you see the
horses you know what sticking out and
they're Consolidated right right those
things are probably a lot of money and
he's probably scraping by and he threw
the thing in shotgun and he's got to get
him to the fair right the parades aren't
paying what they used to be that's right
he couldn't this be his support animal
listen we see annoying people with their
little Yorkies in their lap when they're
driving and if his is a one ton Watson
bouldin it's America right I'm surprised
those tires are holding up with that big
bull in there he weighs a lot of pounds
Hydraulics first that's a nice guy nice
little yeah oh look at the back side of
the car did you see that I mean
that's disgusting over it oh yeah
you can't see through it first of all
bulls have rights okay yeah and you know
what they should be able to ride shotgun
as opposed to being in one of those
hidden U-Haul things that's animal abuse
the maddest thing about this story but I
read it was you know what the police did
they stopped the car they interviewed
the driver
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else